Друзі, всім привіт!
У ваших коментарях ви неодноразово просили показати,
як працює громадський транспорт у Німеччині.
Тож у цій серії – моя розповідь про те,
як організована транспортна система Бонна і Кельна.
Розпочнемо з міської електрички - штадтбану -
це такий собі гібрид метро і трамвая.
Цікаво, що у Кельні та Бонні
штадтбан  одночасно є і  міським, і приміським потягом.
Окрім зручної мережі станцій, маршрути до яких проходять через ці два міста
над і під землею, штадтбан ще й з'єднує Кельн з Бонном,
між якими 30 кілометрів.
Штадтбан перетинається з іншими видами транспорту,
тож саме цьому ці електрички не можна вважати
повноцінним метро. На всіх станціях є ліфти
або спеціальні ескалатори для людей з інвалідністю.
Друзі, подивіться, на вході до станції
немає ніяких турнікетів.
Таке побачиш далеко не в усіх європейських країнах.
Такий вхід - просто мрія транспортних зайців.
Незважаючи на штраф за проїзд без квитка у 60 євро,
бажаючі покататися безкоштовно щороку
завдають збитків транспортним компаніям Німеччини
на 250 мільйонів євро.
Контролери заходять по троє або п'ятеро у вагон –
щоб підтримати один одного і викликати поліцію
у разі агресивної поведінки безбілетника.
Якщо «заєць» не матиме при собі посвідчення особи,
його теж передають у поліцію.
Квитки і на Штадтбан і на автобус можна купити в такому автоматі.
До меню, звичайно, треба звикнути.
Тут категорія дорослі, тут діти,
а тут квиток, який діє 24 години.
На квитку зазначено, що він вже закомпостований,
праворуч  внизу проставлена дата, місце і час його придбання.
Квиток діє півтори години в одному напрямку
на всі види транспорту.
А в цій сірій, бетонній будівлі у Кельні сидять ті,
хто вирішує, чому з нового року проїзд більше п'яти зупинок
коштує 3 євро, а не 2.80 як минулоріч.
VRS - Транспортний союз регіону Райн-Зіг.
Пан Кляйн пояснює, з чого складається тариф на проїзд.
Енергія -  дизель для автобусів, струм для транспорту  -
це 20 відсотків.
Матеріал – закупівля нових автобусів –
це теж близько 20 відсотків.
Персонал – ці витрати становлять
60 відсотків вартості квитка.
Водії автобусів і потягів хочуть отримувати більші зарплати.
Їх підвищують десь раз на два роки.
І ці гроші ми маємо отримати через тарифи на квитки.
Ну що ж, тепер давайте подивимось, куди йдуть кошти,
закладені у тариф квитка.
А зараз ми у транспортній майстерні підприємства КVB.
І сьогодні мені тут допомагатиме пан Анемюллер.
Майстерня займає площу восьми футбольних полів.
а рік тут ремонтують до 400 вагонів електротранспорту.
Раз на 5 років, коли пробіг вагону становить близько
500 тисяч кілометрів, він має пройти обов'язковий техогляд.
Показники, які я тут вимірюю, це як тахометр в автомобілі.
І це норми, яких я маю дотримуватися, щоб усі вони  збігалися.
У нас є чотири колеса, які пов'язані між собою
і повинні відповідати певним нормам.
З німецькою педантичністю всі ходові частини розфасовані
на багатометрових стелажах.
Тут у нас як на автомобільній СТО, на якій знаходяться багато колес -
одне треба відремонтувати, інше вже встановлене.
І ці червоні, жовті і зелені картки кажуть колегам,
в якому стані ці деталі.
Червоний колір означає, цим треба зайнятися.
Жовтий - вже відремонтовано,
але потрібно протестувати.
Зелений - все готове і можна встановлювати.
Окрім техогляду і заміни запчастин,
майстерня проводить і капітальний ремонт вагонів.
Транспортна компанія Кельна робить ставку
на повну модернізацію старих вагонів.
Капітальний ремонт такого потяга коштує близько мільйона 700 тисяч євро,
а за новий ми маємо віддати три мільйони двісті тисяч.
Це значить модернізація коштує нам половину.
За ці гроші в Німеччині ми можемо купити ще вагонів
або відремонтувати зупинки.
Фактично від старого вагону залишають лише залізний каркас.
Електродвигун, проводку, начиння, ходову і зовнішні панелі замінюють.
Ось так виглядає вагон, якому 35 років,
а це цей же ж вагон після реконструкції.
Нова лакована фарба, звичайно, справляє вау-ефект,
а що ж видно з оглядової ями?
А ось так виглядає реконструйований вагон штадтбану знизу –
фактично як новий.
І питання, яке я виношую весь час перебування в Німеччині–
який графік миття  громадського транспорту.
Мийка ззовні – залежно від забруднення
раз на два або три тижні.
Всередині – вимивають щодня.
А тепер запитаю у пасажирів, чи задоволені вони тим,
як ходить штадтбан у Бонні і Кельні.
Кожні кілька хвилин приходить потяг.
Я можу вибирати, їхати на ньому, йти пішки чи на автобусі.
Я їжджу на штадтбані щодня.
Я відносно задоволений ним, окрім випадків,
коли взимку поїзди часом скасовують.
Пропоную простий експеримент.
Я проїду з Бонна до Кельна один і той самий маршрут
на машині і на транспорті, і подивимось, чим буде швидше.
Навігатор обіцяє на автівці 33 кілометри за 34 хвилини.
Пішов дощ, рух на автобані трохи сповільнився.
Однак мені пощастило, заторів не було.
Доїхав за 40 хвилин.
Ну що ж, а тепер давайте подивимось,
за який проміжок часу я доїду на електричці з Бонна до Кельна.
Їду на потязі типу RB - Regionalbahn -
який курсує регіональними маршрутами з частими зупинками.
Смартфон-додаток Дойче Бана – німецької залізниці -
обіцяє 40 хвилин у дорозі.
Той самий час, який я проїхав на автівці.
У потязі типу RB є розподіл на перший і другий класи.
Друзі, подивіться – а цей вагон називається «Мрія велосипедиста».
Поки милувався електровелосипедами,
поруч розгорталася драма – контролер упіймав «зайця».
Я тридцять років їздив цим маршрутом з проїзним від роботи.
А сьогодні потяг не прийшов.
Оплатите - і все в порядку.
А у мене запис до лікаря.
На залізничному вокзалі Кельна контролер натискає
зелену кнопку на дверях – вона є у всіх вагонах,
і двері відчиняються лише тоді, коли хтось натискає на неї.
Все заради економії енергії.
На вокзалі привернув увагу студент, який довго не міг вибрати
правильний квиток в автоматі.
Для мене процес придбання квитка у цьому автоматі є не найпростішим.
Краще поговорити з працівниками вокзалу у касі,
які можуть продати правильний квиток.
Це треба робити швидко, а це складно,
і можна пропустити свій потяг.
Друзі, а тепер, найцікавіша деталь про центральний залізничний вокзал Кельна.
Ось я з нього виходжу і подивіться – розвертаюсь
і ось він – величний Кельнський собор.
А це 9-метрова копія хрестоцвіту,
який стоїть аж отам на самому вершечку собору.
До речі, якщо вам цікаво дізнатися про інші туристичні пам'ятки Німеччини
та як тут влаштований туризм – пишіть у ваших коментарях.
Дойче Баном щодня ходять 40 тисяч поїздів,
з них - 24 тисячі пасажирських,
що перевозять на добу понад сім мільйонів людей.
Останніми роками через поламки потягів і колій
виникають багато запізнень.
У 2018 році німецька залізниця
витратила на компенсації пасажирам
понад 53 мільйони євро.
Закон ЄС дозволяє пасажиру вимагати компенсації,
якщо поїзд запізнився у пункт призначення щонайменше на годину.
Так виглядає центр Бонна у годину пік.
Найрозповсюдженіший вид транспорту у Німеччині - автобус.
У невеликих містах і селищах автобус є основним громадським транспортом.
У Бонні левову частку маршрутів обслуговує транспортне підприємство SWB.
Загалом у нас працюють  шістсот власних водіїв автобусів,
а також найманий персонал.
Виконують рейси близько двохсот автобусів.
Це звичайна боннська автобусна зупинка.
Електронне табло показує, скільки часу залишилося до наступного автобуса.
Таблиця з розкладом вказує, що кожен маршрут
на цій зупинці ходить тричі на годину.
Квиток в боннському автобусі можна купити прямо у водія.
У  Кельні вже не так – там в автобусах стоять автомати.
Запитаю, як працюється водіям у Бонні.
Я у змішаній групі, що стосується робочих змін.
Я їжджу за різними графіками: один тиждень вранці,
один вдень, один ввечері, і навіть вночі іноді.
Звичайно, робочий графік може стати ще кращим,
я сподіваюся, що так і станеться у майбутньому.
Загалом все у порядку.
Мені приносить велике задоволення водити автобус.
По всьому салону розташовані червоні кнопки,
якими треба попереджати водія про те, що на наступній зупинці ви виходите.
Якщо цього не зробити і на зупинці ніхто не чекатиме, водій поїде далі.
А це водійка автобусу Андреа з кельнської транспортної компанії KVB.
Вона приїздить на роботу на велосипеді.
Початок робочого дня – огляд автобуса
для візуального виявлення можливих несправностей.
І далі – вперед на маршрут.
За день стається багато різних ситуацій.
Якщо пасажир біжить до автобуса і хоче терміново в нього сісти,
а я не запізнююсь і перебуваю ще на зупинці,
тоді я почекаю на пасажира.
Але якщо я запізнююсь або вже зрушила,
то в мене немає інших варіантів.
І я вважаю, якщо я вже виїхала і мій колега прибуде незабаром,
то пасажир може вже й почекати ті дві хвилини.
У всіх німецьких автобусів підлога опускається до рівня бордюру.
Водій зобов'язаний вийти і допомогти людям з інвалідністю.
А тепер подивимося, де ремонтують і обслуговують кельнські автобуси.
Ремонтна майстерня транспортної компанії KVB.
Одразу впадає в очі фірмова плакетка  TÜV -
що це за організація, яка перевіряє технічний стан автомобілів,
можете подивитися в одній із попередніх серій відеоблогу.
Виявляється на автобусній станції обслуговування можна пройти
і сертифікований тест на технічний стан,
бо тут є офіційне відділення TÜV.
Зараз перевіряють гальма у машині
технічної допомоги автобусного парку.
Я підключаю зараз закачування повітря до автобуса.
Щоб ми могли їхати, щоб це було на належному рівні,
щоб гальма працювали, бо нам потрібен тиск повітря.
Штефан Анемюллер наголосив, що на рейсах у Кельні -
автобуси Ман і Мерседес, тож деталі і агрегати
на заміну постачають лише ці дві компанії.
Це дуже важливо, адже є багато компаній на ринку запчастин,
які пропонують деталі за значно нижчими цінами.
Однак деталі мають бути перевіреними, допущеними до експлуатації,
призначені для відповідного автомобіля, щоб усе працювало.
Чистота як і в майстерні вагонів Штадтбану –
пляму мастила одразу вимивають спеціальною машиною.
Мене вразило, що 19-метрові автобуси піднімають на домкратах,
і ніхто не працює у оглядових ямах під автобусами.
Ми можемо цей автобус піднімати вгору і опускати донизу.
Тож працівник, який має щось відремонтувати чи подивитися під автобусом,
може все робити стоячи, не нахилятися і повертатися -
і так 3-4 години в день.
Умови роботи завжди такі, щоб працівники залишатися здоровими.
Фото на згадку з рейсовим автобусом у повітрі.
Друзі, пишіть у коментарях, що ще вам цікаво знати про Німеччину,
і я обов'язково про це розповім у наступній серії.